foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday man I just it just
I should have made crust
for the pumpkin pie
I should have made the pie I was like oh
yeah if you weren't around like we were
talking about before the stream came on
it's like I should have made crusts
doesn't really sound like a good opening
snack talking about a [ __ ] crust for
the party for the pumpkin pie because
you got all the stuff to make the
pumpkin pie he just doesn't happen yeah
should have made the crust yeah make two
pumpkin pies and I'll sing about making
pumpkin pie too all right all right
that's all right all right so as long as
you actually make them that would be
yeah I [ __ ] a mother two up had to
throw them away but I'm not gonna talk
about that I'm not gonna mention that oh
that's right I forgot about it yeah now
I'm gonna make fun of you all over again
about it I have forgotten all of that
yeah that's milk in them whoops well you
know that it happened
my man these aren't very sweet he's like
man these are gross the texture isn't
good this isn't sweet oh condensed milk
I forgot [ __ ] that's funny he didn't
even like tell me no I didn't even find
out about it he was just like
that [ __ ] away
married
and then the Bears came and got him oh
yeah that's right the Bears got into the
car yeah the other day they smelled it
yeah they're like Oh They'll eat it well
at least it didn't go to waste like this
is good
I like that sweet [ __ ] they usually oh
Harvey over here Harvey she's good man
yeah he's like yeah give me a piece of
that don't hog it okay they're showing
up this one was uh
a good episode
the Unleashed Unleashed kind of similar
to the one we did last week I think was
called Spellbound right yeah this is
kind of similar this one actually has um
who was it that recommended this do you
remember who recommended it Danny did it
yeah sir yeah Daddy always recommended
[ __ ] well he's seen them all he's seen
them all and and he recommends ones that
I noticed he kind of recommends the ones
that fall within uh Tom uh uh Tom's
[ __ ] rspk hypothesis he wants me to
[ __ ] call it or just you know
basically you know Sith Sith Lords
[ __ ] using [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
subconsciously and this one does caught
up this one does follow that
the Tom hypothesis that wasn't mine but
the
topothesis yeah that's what I'm gonna
call it it does based on my personal
experience that's this is what I've seen
and some of this does fall a lot of this
in general Falls Within
um kind of what happened to me and my
family
it's just that it's tainted by religion
you know his religion but that falls
right within rspk it manifests itself in
whatever the person's belief system is
but then there's like books involved
with this and there may be some Churches
involved with this Jenny Jenny did some
back well a a book A book with bunny
rabbit ears just because okay should I
just should I just say I mean the book
is on it's on Amazon but it's only 68
pages or something like that which that
doesn't mean anything because Jenny
wrote a book about half Mountain about
what you know what at least mine was
like longer so you felt like you were
getting your money's worth so um
from what I've seen so far at least from
the episode I haven't done the the Deep
dive like Jetties did which we're going
to get into it but based on the episode
I think it's plausible this this may be
a real case but we'll see yeah I mean I
didn't like I said I didn't do a super
deep dive on it because I just I just
found out that there was a book about it
that the guy had written a book and that
it's not I don't think it's available
anymore but
um the reviews of it were
a little scathing yeah in like too short
huh short story well people yeah one was
it was two shorts they kind of felt like
they got ripped off
um two a couple people complained
because they're like this is like
stealth evangelism okay
um and a couple people said uh this
guy's either illiterate or playing an
illiterate on TV or something like that
okay so I'm guessing that he didn't
really have anybody edited I don't know
I didn't read it but I'm just saying
besides that it's a good episode oh it's
fun to watch uh dude started and it kind
of looks like a cross between Tom Hardy
and [ __ ] Richard Dreyfuss more like
Richard Dreyfuss again I thought he
looked a little bit like Tom Hardy or
Logan Marshall greeny you know what I
mean he looks kind of like that a little
bit like the actor that's playing the
main guy not not the actual guy and he
[ __ ] around found out man [ __ ]
around with that paranormal you know
that's what you do you like you [ __ ]
around with witchcraft the [ __ ] around
find out [ __ ] there's a whole bar graph
for [ __ ] around and finding out he
[ __ ] around it's pentagram shaped in
this yes
[ __ ] around with that [ __ ] you go find
out well see that's what that's why I'm
saying that's why it was similar to like
the Spellbound one because you got the
mom in that one and she was just like
all into Wicca and like look how that
turned out she's all right Jesus showed
up fixed it
Jesus is just all right with me yeah
Jesus is just I don't care what a dead
man said
we're trying to figure out what song
that was well I know what song it is I
just can't remember like what band did
it because I just can't because I'm
getting so Jesus shows up and fix it
which that doesn't that doesn't exclude
this from being
um legitimate [ __ ] rspk response to
whatever whatever person belief whatever
they believe if they're if they're
Muslim it's going to be Muhammad and
Jinn you know that's the way it's going
to come across if he's the person is
kind of secular it's going to come
across as like psychic forces you know
um if a person is Christian it's going
to come in a Christian Motif so it still
fits within uh Tom's hypothesis the the
the hypothesis the hypothesis of [ __ ]
the tamaverse yeah
[Laughter]
Stephen King's got his own the extended
time of her [ __ ] Marvel's got their
Universe Tom's got his Universe there's
another t-shirt the extended Thomas and
then you could have like all of your
little things that you like on you like
all around like your little bald head in
the middle yeah she's what they call in
England she's taking a piss I'm not
taking this I'm being totally serious
okay actually we should do like a
drawing of you from the side like of
your little bald head and then like on
the inside we'll do like a little brain
and then it'll be it'll be in little
parts that have all your little
interests yeah and then it would be like
the extended time reverse in the
universe in the UK they call it taking
the piss in the South here in the United
States they just call it [ __ ] with
you yeah I'm just [ __ ] with you I'm
just [ __ ] with you just messing
that's another one that's the clean
that's the that's the PG version just
medicine or just picking that's another
one yeah just pick it
that's what church girls would say I'm
just picking
that sounds kind of gross though yeah
picking on you picking on you yeah I'm
not picking I was being totally serious
I'm just picking
okay now now he's picking on me that's
like a Church Girl Say okay we got
there's some announcements here um wait
Danny says they fouled up by not having
the daughter in the protection Circle
yeah you're right they were just like
screw that girl what was she like 11 she
was 511. like she was growing up on the
she's protected by the but she's
protected by Jesus she's like I'm not
even involved in this [ __ ] I'm just
gonna be over here by the coffee table
her innocence protected her I gotta
playing with Play-Doh or whatever the
[ __ ]
um you're like are you a virgin you are
okay then you're gonna be okay just
stand up there she better be she's alive
[Laughter]
yeah
ew all right so uh yeah got a couple of
announcements we got a new Patron you
guys yay I'm always excited when that
happens uh their name is seven lines
that's what they're so thank you very
much seven seven lines lines l-i-n-e-s
are limes with the m lines okay like
lines of cocaine sounds good lines
if you've got enough alcohol in you you
could do all seven I wouldn't recommend
it you won't even notice I wouldn't
recommend it yeah like the Cowboys used
to do it all the time
well they were Cowboys yeah they're
cowboys just keep drinking keep drinking
the law balance out yeah
uh and also got a big box from Chewie
today yes we did a dress to Pookie it
was it was actually addressed to Pookie
Ashford
it said Pookie Ashford so Pookie took
Mommy it's a Pookie took mommy's last
name yeah
evidently it's okay that's okay and it
was full of her favorite
tuna
Sheba meat sticks she was very excited
like as soon as I opened the box her
little head pops up like is is that for
me it is for you today she knows what uh
chewy wrapping which with the chewy
wrappers look like you need to come from
chewy she knows oh she was that's for me
she knows the boxes and everything you
open oh she suspects all boxes belonger
well that's what I think it's anytime
it's a box she always runs in it it's
like for Pokey because sometimes it is
because you know I get Temptations like
from shooting and stuff like that but
when cat stuff comes out she recognizes
it oh meat stick oh
she knows exactly oh that's for me
she's [ __ ] funny hilarious
but yeah and I can't remember
I know somebody asked probably on the
Friday night show I want to say like
what pokey's favorite uh treat was and I
think I said what it was but I can't
remember who it was it sent it but
somebody but thank you whoever said it
if you're in the comments then let me
know
uh Zach says also I loved the Chinatown
video thank you very much we finally got
around to
doing that you know what was so good
about the Chinatown one go ahead and
give me some feedback in there so we so
we can keep it up
Zach says Pookie Ashford sounds like the
love interest in a Nickelodeon cartoon
2005.
poker could be a porn name though
don't say that yeah
now you're now you're making it could be
a porn name don't don't make don't
associate that's a black girl's name in
porn yeah
see I just named her Pookie because I
mean I we didn't even name her that
that's not her actual name it's just her
nickname yeah it is Pookie but um I
started calling her that because she
looks like a little teddy bear and it
reminded me of remember the old Garfield
yeah uh comic strip and Garfield had a
teddy bear named Pookie yeah and she
looks kind of like that like when she
lays down with her little short legs
like in her little belly I'm not sure
what pokey's actual real name is we've
kind of forgot it over there
because she had several of them well it
took us a long time because we were kind
of like
we didn't know I said well I want to
give her a good name like that that
suits her personality baby Cookie was
her yeah real name but it's like nothing
really like
nothing really seemed to fit you know
what I mean I don't know why yeah but
other than Pookie yeah
because I guess I don't know what it was
like the way she moved around to me just
like it it just made me think of like
pookaling I said you look like you're
poochling the way that you're moving
she started off with a [ __ ] up boy's
name that they just gave it to her with
that I don't even remember that was like
from the lady that found her
and then um because the lady that found
her thought she was a boy yeah because
she was lit she was little she was a
tiny tiny kitten and then she just she
gave us the the the cat in a line of
some fake Story how she found it
no she says she found it it's had its
tail bitten off by the dogs and I was
just looking at that and going that's a
Manx
you know but she was a Brazilian and
even when we took her to the vet you
know the vet was pretty much like yeah
I'm pretty sure that's just the way your
tail is it doesn't look like it's like
wounded already she's a Brazilian you
know I grew up in Brazil and Brazilian
girls will tell you stories and they
don't know anything about European cat
breeds I'm looking at it I'm going
that's a Manx yeah
and I don't think they have Max cats in
Brazil
they may but she didn't know about them
she thought the cat still got bitten off
and I'm looking at that and I'm going oh
I felt it and it didn't feel like
there's anything wrong with it the event
cat was born like that
yeah
it didn't look yeah it didn't look like
it was wounded or anything it looked
like it was supposed to be like that and
we ended up calling the cat baby Pookie
baby cook Maybe Cookie and then then it
[ __ ] slowly after the baby on uh beer
and board games
the little the little infant baby that
like swears and takes drugs and stuff
yeah I said that kind of seems like what
pokies that's which personality is like
I was like the closest that was the
closest thing and I said if she talks
that's kind of what she would sound like
a baby that has a boyfriend yeah yeah
yeah and smokes and drinks and does
drugs yeah
it takes raft rides in the gutter yeah
I was like yeah that seems about like it
literally was a baby a human baby doll
yeah that they use as a public and naked
baby doll yeah it's not even yeah it's
not even a puppet they just kind of like
hold it back give it a voice they shake
it at the screen and then Matt slow does
them yeah it was [ __ ] hilarious
baby uh baby Cookie still shows up on
the show every now and then yeah every
now and then so uh so yeah uh we went
down the the cat Rabbit Hole or the cat
hole if you want to call it that yeah
but um yeah I'm not sure who sent all of
the
sheep and meat sticks but thank you very
much Pookie is very excited about it
because that's her very very favorite
thing and she comes in every evening
wanting several of them
and trying to get a new one every time
she comes in like trying to be sneaky
Zach's going on about how cute young
Richard Dreyfuss was and how young he
was yeah and how cute young uh Jack
Nicholson was and that he was mad that
we didn't mention how cute he was in
Chinatown yeah he was in good he he was
at his height in terms of like uh his
acting ability too I thought that was he
could always act I mean he could act
yeah but um he was stretching it into a
roll that you don't normally see him
play like you know a [ __ ] upstanding
kind of guy you know in a way you know
[ __ ] a heroic
type of guy he was very restrained which
he didn't usually see later he's trying
to protect it yeah you know but you
could tell there was a lot going on like
other than a couple of times where he
got like really upset and like busted
out but you know what I mean so I was
like a lot more restrained role than he
usually played and yeah he was really
good in that I think a lot of people
think that is easily one of his best
roles I'm just like losing stuff
everywhere I didn't have time to like
type the notes for this but I did write
them all down here in my thing so
so if I drop my and Tom just watched it
yeah because I watched it last night but
he fell asleep I'll see him doing it and
so he just watched it again like about I
fell asleep during the intro
yeah as soon as the music came on I
started relaxing
yeah
you're at your bar and then we did the
Pulp Fiction review and you drank on
that yeah and so I went I went in like
you know half an hour later and put the
The Haunting on and he just was like
laying there watching it and like yeah
and then woke up because uh started to
damn murder mystery about this uh
bodybuilder girl who shot her boyfriend
her husband yeah she was in the Marines
and I remember when that happened killer
Sally killer Sally yeah she was cute she
was cute I think I think I've been in
the 90s yeah real cute bodybuilder chick
married to this good looking black dude
she was blonde they were both
bodybuilders yeah they were both
bodybuilders he made it into Olympia
they were both in the Marines together
he made it into Olympia [ __ ] place to
I think 16th 15th 15th 16th which is
[ __ ] good
he he was going to leave her and she got
jealous and [ __ ] they were always
fighting and [ __ ] and he said she shot
him twice
he was also very abusive he was abusive
too they were I think they were both
hot-headed if you asked me I think they
were it did seem like they were in a
toxic relationship
and uh she was making [ __ ]
underground wrestling videos and written
if you want to wrestle at the end of the
video she'd be like if you want to
wrestle me call me at this number we'll
make a video she said she was making all
kinds of money doing these sexy
wrestling but she'd wrestle with some
dudes
and beat him up
yeah they got you guys into it I'd do
that yeah I wrestle yeah I wrestle with
you babe and then we'll make a video
Jenny [ __ ] should do the lighting and
everything
like she's wrapping his ass up you know
and then like um
she was making money to uh because
her husband's [ __ ] to get to Olympia
you need a lot of money for steroids
because she they take a lot you know
[ __ ] 10 times what I take so I can't
imagine [ __ ] spending up that 500 one
thousand dollars a [ __ ] month on that
[ __ ] that's a lot
got to buy a lot of drugs
yep gotta buy a lot of desserts they
take a lot yeah
and he was like at the time he got
killed he was on five different ones at
the same time a huge stack which you
know I try to see the stack they showed
it real quick but they they
it was only on for a second I couldn't
read them all one of them was [ __ ]
Deca he was on a Deca and he was on a
bunch of other stuff but it didn't
really
I don't think that really
didn't uh that really didn't make a
difference in this case
yeah I just stumbled across it on uh
Netflix and I thought oh look it's true
crime which I like and bodybuilding
which Tom likes I was like so let's
watch that it was like a minis it was
like three episodes or something like
that but like a true crime kind of thing
I don't remember a lot about that case I
remember hearing about it but no I think
it was 94 or 95 something like that yeah
the United [ __ ] can make you volatile
especially in in real high doses but
they were she shot him and she wasn't on
anything she was on one yeah it was
anavar though yeah it was that that's
not that's it yeah that's weak
she just did that for maintenance
but uh okay go ahead all right so let's
start talking about this haunting
episode which is called the Unleashed
it's like uh season three episode four I
think it is yeah so the guy at the
center of this is named Randy Irvin and
that's Irvin with an e e r v i n like I
said he did write a book it's on Amazon
um it's called the house on Church
Street like I'm assuming he
self-published it like I said it's only
60 odd pages long I don't remember how
much it costs I don't know how available
it is but yeah he did uh write a book
about this experience and like I said
it's kind of like it some of the um the
reviews of it were mad because it was
like stealth Evangelical you know what I
mean like it was supposed to be just
like a paranormal thing but then they
were like oh by the way Jesus you know
what I mean uh so this took place in
Standish Michigan near Lake Huron right
1974. So Randy Irvin is 22 years old
when this takes place and he's lived in
Standish all of his life
and he starts working at the post office
and moves into an old house that his dad
had been renovating because I guess his
dad would lose like a house flipper like
they didn't call it that back then but
that's what they would call it now so
he'd buy houses and fix them up and then
rent them out or sell them or whatever
so while his dad is digging in the
basement of this latest house that he's
working on he finds a human bone
or what looks like a human bone
so he shows Randy the bone he's like
look at this [ __ ] you know what I mean
as you would
um and then they start another show that
he found like a whole bunch of them now
I don't
I remember looking at that and they were
like I wonder if that's a human bone I'm
like yeah that definitely looks like a
human body the fever bone it looked like
but it looked like he had a bunch of
them and then it looked like all femurs
I was like it was it a person that was
all famous it was just like a person
with all legs was a leg hair and a leg
here and a leg here that was a head on
hand I guess so they're like don't you
have any other like don't you have a rib
cage or something like that yeah you
deal with six people here
[Laughter]
just femurs so uh so yeah they were at
that point they were like well because I
don't know if it was all femurs or not
but that's just what it looked like on
the show
so they're saying they didn't
necessarily think oh it's like a murder
victim because it looked like it was
more than one so what they assumed was
that it's the good old uh Chestnut the
Native American burial ground uh they
said which you know there's a lot of
those in Standish so whatever so like
digging in the basement under the house
and you find a bunch of Bones and they
figure hey that's probably and they
called somebody from like the University
or some [ __ ] like that and they said
yeah that's probably what it is
so they figure
um well we're just gonna put the bones
back like out of respect you know what I
mean because that's where they got
buried and it's like we don't need to
move them anywhere or anything like that
so they decide to put them back in there
So Randy is kind of like I guess he's
living in this house and he's kind of
like wigged out by all these bones down
there under which I don't you know I
guess that'd be weird but I mean you
might have bones under your house right
now and just like not know about it just
don't worry about it
um you know what I mean it's like
they're both everywhere don't worry
about it so uh so he starts researching
and for whatever reason I don't really
know like how he made this connection in
his mind but because he there were these
bones and they thought there was a
Native American burial ground under this
house he is for some reason drawn to
he's in a bookstore and he's drawn to a
book about witchcraft because
for reasons I don't know why
so he's running a book on witchcraft and
he finds this book and it tells how to
summon spirits up and he's like oh that
sounds like a good idea doesn't it
so he uh I think one of the reasons was
then again this doesn't really have
anything to do with like the bones he
found necessarily but he's like I want
to summon some spirits that are going to
help me find treasure because I guess
that's what that's what he said right
yeah
I think that's what it was he just said
he was interested in the occult anyway
you just kind of a rebellious guy
you know they show them just kind of a
mild manner Richard Dreyfuss type
looking dude you know make him making a
mountain out of [ __ ] mashed potatoes
in his living room but uh I mean you
figured in police yeah that was under
the impression that he was kind of like
in a metal head you know in the Black
Sabbath or some [ __ ] like that during
the time
it's hard to say you know what I mean
with this show what that you know you
got a guy he's telling you one thing and
then you got you got a haunting they're
showing you con you know something based
on what so you so you don't really yeah
and you're not really sure how much of
it how much of the reenactment is just
like a haunting being like we're gonna
make this more interesting or how much
of it is yeah based on something that
the person told them but doesn't
necessarily yeah like say out loud you
know what I mean yeah now what the way
he's set in the scene here
there could be something to this
he finds
he moves into a place pretty much by
himself
finds human bones
in the basement
they re-berry him which might
bring some internal conflict you're now
kind of have a dark shadow over the
house so there's an element of fear yeah
I mean you're like was that a murder
victim or was this an Indian burial
ground what was that yeah I think I'd
have gone to the authorities
yeah I mean just to be on the safe side
yeah because if it's a murder victim you
don't really want to yeah they'll take
it out and go see and they go oh no
these things are hundreds of years old
you're good yeah dude it could have been
something like that you know or like no
this is from 20 years ago yeah we need
it we need to find out what happened to
this person right you know that might be
a female victim somebody [ __ ] raped
and killed or buried her that's what I
mean she might have been missing all
this time and like her family didn't
know where she was I think I'd have told
the cops
maybe there was some internal conflict
about that in him if this happened I'm
saying if this story happened yeah I
mean that's there's just a caveat we
always give with these right so he's now
got this internal conflict in him
there's a dead body down there we're not
in it you know and it's it's either
Indians and they're going to come and
get me
maybe it's a murder victim you know what
I mean and I didn't tell the cops so
there's now kind of an underlying
tension
so then he goes to an occult bookstore
which he saw right now he's already kind
of opened up kind of some uh the
possibility into all that jungian
psychology that maybe the Paranormal
exists
so if you know anything about you know
like Quantum Consciousness you know from
Stuart hammeroff you know the part of
your Consciousness is going to be
existing slightly outside the normal
Realms of three spatial Dimensions so
you know you
you're now starting to
possibly fuel something paranormal that
emanates from within yourself
um so and I think that's kind of what
ends up happening
he now tries to call on a spirit
well it's more likely you could create a
spirit
something kind of like a dream creature
and what are your dreams but now it's
fueled by it has its own psychic energy
behind it you're going to feel it and
it's going to almost kind of like the
old Jewish story of a goal of a Golem
you know except instead of it being
physical it's now
spiritual it's you've created a
poltergeist basically that's it is
you've created a poltergeist
you think it's an outside force
so just the story right there it's
plausible that that's a bad situation
that might set something up like that
and he did really seem to want to
conjure something yeah
because he gets this book and like I
said at least according to him he said I
wanted to summon the spirit specifically
to find treasure yeah form like I don't
know where he got the idea that there'd
be any treasure to find or what or what
I don't know they didn't really go into
that so the subconscious starts to
[ __ ] Manifest this psychic force in
the form of a spirit
I don't think it's the spirit of a dead
I think it's it's him doing it
you know as a character he's created
like a Golem yeah I mean that does seem
like the more like this scenario which
is that's what a poltergeist is you know
I've seen it
Jenny's seated it didn't have a
personality when she saw it but if it's
around long enough it'll start to
developing it'll it'll it'll meet any
expectations you have
if you think it's a demon it'll start
acting like a demon
if you think it's a dead person it'll
try to it'll try to be that dead person
that's just but it's not real you know
it's just like a character in your
dreams those aren't real people but they
sure can convince you in that dream that
it's a real person
and other things happening like
spiritual dogs and animals makes me
think this is like this is Poltergeist
these are fragments of fragments of his
dreaming subconscious or you know is
making these things
yeah so he goes home and I guess like I
said it's his dad's house I guess his
dad owned the house but he was renting
it from his dad I'm assuming was the set
up there
but he was living there by himself so he
goes and he gets the book and uh he's
like okay so the book says that you have
to
um you know just it has to be dark and
you have to have no noise and no
distractions and all this other kind of
stuff he's gonna so you can like
concentrate on everything like control
your environment so then he sits there
in the chair in the middle of the room
in the dark and he's got his hands out
and he's like you know summoning the
spirits like saying the names of them
you know what I mean just like over and
over like calling him out he's like and
he kept doing it over and over but
nothing happened
um so he's kind of like on the show they
showed him doing it and he's just like
what the [ __ ] like nothing's happening
and then something like Falls over
but they kind of left it ambiguous
because he had the windows open so like
the curtain kind of blew and maybe the
curtain like knocked the [ __ ] over or
something like that but uh so he keeps
doing it and like still nothing happens
so he's bummed out he's like um I
thought like according to the book that
the spirits were supposed to show up
like right away so what the [ __ ] like
what's taking him so long I guess
um so nothing happens but then like I
guess he goes to sleep that night it's
fine but then the next night he's
sleeping in bed and he gets woke up by a
noise that sounds like he said it
sounded like dishes like clanking or
like rattling like in the kitchen yeah
that's what he said it sounded like
that's that's very reminiscent of
poltergeist
just digs rattling in rooms where
there's no nobody in there
where you can hear things
like Furniture being drugged across the
floor and it's in a room where the door
is closed there's no way you enter out
of there and you know something moving
in there and you open up the damn door
and look and try to catch it you know
see a chair upturned in the middle of
the room it wasn't like that before just
a few seconds before you know so you
know something moved in there that's
what he's talking about yeah this is
Poltergeist I mean he heard that and
like he goes in the kitchen and nothing
was in there and like nothing looked
amiss like nothing looked like it was
out of place but then he hears what
sounded like he said it sounded like
someone walking like in the living room
like while he was in the kitchen yeah
but of course he goes in there and of
course there's no one there either so he
thought that was like a little bit weird
yeah any kind of phantom noise
Poltergeist can
can mimic anything when it comes to
sounds and noises so it doesn't surprise
me it's still fitting within Poltergeist
now the next morning apparently
his mom Belva calls and she lives in
Mississippi with Randy's younger sister
his name is Tammy and Tammy was 11 at
the time like I said this was 1974.
so they're trying to imply I guess that
his mom was having like a psychic
kind of uh feeling that something was
the matter so she like calls him up and
it's like I feel like something's wrong
and I needed to come back and like
because I guess she used to live in
Michigan too but like she moved down to
Mississippi or whatever she's like I
feel like I need to come back there
because I feel like something bad is
going to happen or I feel like
something's wrong
so Belva and Tammy the sister they
actually leave Mississippi and they move
in with Randy like a month later so okay
so they move in there
they said when he got when they got
there they said he looked really really
pale and thin and tired because a month
has gone by like since he summoned the
spirits you're led to assume so you know
he's getting all drained and whatnot
now uh at least according to the show
when they have Belva come in like the
mom she looks like she kind of Senses
something in the house like she comes in
and she's like whoa I don't like it in
here kind of deal
um and then like one night everybody is
sleeping and then they get woke up in
the middle of the night by an organ
playing like what sounded like an organ
playing yeah it's a creepy scene it is
yeah that's actually very creepy one of
the best this is one of the best scenes
in this episode it was very Carnival of
Souls yeah
he wakes up
and he's trying to look and see where
it's coming from and his mom runs and he
goes will you turn that radio down
because there is no radio
it's just kind of creepy organ music
and there
it's it's coming from a room a corner in
one of the room but they can't find
anything there
and uh man I was still going like man if
they made that up that was very creative
that sounds like something Poltergeist
would do
it's uh I would like to to too bad they
couldn't get a recording of it if it was
actual sound it might have been a
psychic sound or just it projected into
the mind I don't know I mean they all
heard it they all heard it the little
girl came running what's that dude and
said like it's just somebody playing the
radio or what's that noise like I hear
an organ playing no is there there's a
chance it might have been
somebody in another house
may be blasting some music but I think
that has a distinct sound of its own
yeah tell that a sound is coming from
outside the house this evidently sounded
like it was coming from within the room
in a corner but there was nothing
emanating it I would have loved to have
seen that my mind didn't do anything
like that
I mean it made it some sounds
it's on the garbled speech I want and
one on one occasion but music well I'd
like to hear that
that would be really creepy like the way
that I that this actually was like I
thought one of the best scenes in the
episode because it was really creep that
would be you know you would [ __ ] [ __ ]
a brick if you woke up and heard that
[ __ ] in the middle of the night or like
organ music like that like I said like
that's some Carnival of Soul [ __ ] yeah
and just think if you're somehow
psychically
making this effect happen using psychic
abilities
there's a part of your mind that wrote
and composed that music
that's right that you don't normally
have access to
it'd be great to get a damn recording of
that and go yeah that's from my
subconscious mind yeah have you had to
be some weird [ __ ] it's so frustrating
that like so much of your brain is
inaccessible I've had dreams where I
heard songs on the radio that were
[ __ ] fantastic I even remember the
lyrics to them right but then when you
wake up it slowly starts fading away
and I was like man I wish I could write
music I'd write that down
see that's why they encourage you like
if you
um want to uh get into a thing where
it's like you're doing lucid dreaming
and stuff like that it's like you have
to start like waking yourself up in the
middle of the night and like writing it
down like as soon as you wake up because
otherwise you forget it like it just
kind of fritters away that's why usually
if I have a real [ __ ] up dream
like I'll usually come in here and type
it out so I remember it because I use
them for stories and stuff like that
sometimes but you know sometimes I
forget but a lot of times if I have a
real [ __ ] up one I'll write it down
but yeah so the the sound seems to be
coming from like nowhere it seems to be
coming from like a corner or something
where there's like nothing is yeah and
they're moving stuff out of the way
trying to figure out where it's coming
from right yeah I would love to have
seen that now his mom Belva she uh her
theory is that she thinks oh maybe it's
the ghost of my mom because her mom
played the organ or something like that
yeah he wasn't buying it well no because
well the thing about it was that Randy
is like well
um yeah I've been summoning some spirits
and probably that's what it was but he
obviously doesn't tell his mom about it
because
I guess he was like embarrassed you know
what I mean
so then later on Randy hears what sounds
like a dog growling in his room
yeah like and that was that was pretty
creepy too like that dog sound yeah he
said some stuff that kind of lined up
with things that I saw he said he could
hear it was at the foot of his bed
and he could kind of feel it standing on
the bed
growling and the growl was coming out of
nowhere and he'd put his hand through
and it felt cold yeah and that would
that would happen a lot at Mammoth and
over at Lois's house you feel kind of
like a zone of cold
but you're not sure if it's actual
temperature or if it's
or if it's just kind of a [ __ ] weird
psychic effect like I always wondered
you know we didn't have a thermometer or
a laser thermometer or anything like
that back in those days
would have liked to take a thermometer
and put it in that cold and see if it
would register as cold
or if it was just some kind of it almost
kind of felt like a weird electrical
effect felt like it was only on your
skin it didn't really feel like it
penetrated through you like you know
what I mean
we never shivered or anything and never
saw any
um
you know steam coming out of your mouth
or you know fog coming out I never
really saw anything like that I think it
was more of a an illusion of cold in
some way didn't I don't think it was
real
but we would like say do you feel that
like yeah yeah if we could all agree
that we kind of felt it we weren't sure
if it was
actual cold as in temperature you know
yeah so
so he hears the growling obviously
there's nothing nothing there but he
said it sounded like a dog growling like
at the end of the bed and like a cold
feeling like you said now the next
morning Randy doesn't tell them about
that he just says oh I just didn't sleep
very well
um but he's getting to a point where
he's like terrified to be in his room at
night because apparently he kept hearing
these Phantom dog sounds and they showed
I don't know if he saw this or not but
they showed it on the reenactment was
like it looked like something like
walking across his bed like it was dog
paws or something like that like walking
across his bed and kind of like grabbing
at him now he did say that he felt hot
breath on his leg and the feel of like
teeth
like Phantom teeth although it didn't
bite him or break the skin or anything
like that he said It felt so it felt
like a dog was there but there wasn't
like just holding his leg like it was
holding his leg like that yeah that's
kind of what he said that it felt like
that
so at this point uh I guess this
happened several times and he finally
tells his mom what's going on he finally
admits uh I've been summoning spirits
and she's like what you know what I mean
yeah
um and then at this point I was like
this actor kind of looks like Tom Hardy
by the way
um a little bit now while he's talking
to his mom they both hear the ghost
doggy noises
coming from the corner and Belva goes
over there and like puts her hand there
and she says it feels feels cold air
like in the corner where the growling is
coming from
so she picks up a Bible and starts
reading from that because you know she
knows what to do
and uh the growling just kind of Fades
away while she's doing that
So Randy is uh obviously not sleeping
all that well so he's having a hard time
at work because of stress and stuff like
that he's a mailman or like he works for
the post office or whatever
so one evening he's watching TV with his
sister Tammy and here's something like
breathing or walking around or something
like that or something like scratching
at this door he said it was like a
storage room where his dad kept antiques
it looked like it went out of the
basement but I'm not really sure like
what it was
so um so yeah so they hear this
scratching like coming from behind the
story even though there's obviously not
supposed to be anybody in there and so
he calls his mom and is like do you hear
Do you hear that and she said yeah she
heard it too and she leans real close to
the door and it kind of it seemed like
the force kind of like sucked her into
the door yeah it like pulled her in like
it pulled her into the door like not the
door was closed but she was kind of like
you know stuck up the side like her head
was magnetic and there was like a big
magnet on the other side it was kind of
like that so yeah pulled her into the
door
and uh then so then Randy runs against
the Bible and starts reading that and
then the thing uh you know dropped her
like I guess it had her in a Chokehold
or whatever
so at that point they're like nope and
then you just run the [ __ ] out of the
house they're like we didn't know where
we were gonna go we just knew we had to
get the [ __ ] out of there
now at this point actually they did a
smart thing they said uh they left that
night and they moved out I mean they
didn't come back
um I mean they came back later but they
moved somewhere else
so they rent a small house across town
now Randy said he felt really super
guilty for summoning the spirits um and
he tells his mom about that and then he
tells her about the bones under the
house and again mom is just like why the
[ __ ] okay like she's like super shocked
why would you have done that
now the thing about it though is that
which this lines up with with your
theory that it's more Poltergeist
activity because they moved to a whole
other house across town and it starts
happening at that house too so basically
like they're I don't know how long they
were there but basically they were like
yeah it followed us
um Randy's in his room one night at the
bedroom door opens by itself and he
starts hearing the weird noises again
like scratching and people walking
around and [ __ ] like that
um so he decides that he needs help
so he's not like affiliated with any
church which we all know is a bad thing
on these on these haunting shows you're
gonna you're gonna get in trouble if
you're not affiliated with the church
yeah you need that church protect
yourself yeah you need the church to
protect you although I will say that he
goes to
he said he goes to a local Minister
first
and he's basically like
um yeah I need some help because there's
like some demonic [ __ ] or witchcraft or
something like happening in my house and
the minister does not believe that
witchcraft is real yeah and uh he's like
well just have you accepted Jesus and
he's like I don't give a [ __ ] about
accepting Jesus like will you just
[ __ ] help me like get this [ __ ]
demon out my house and basically like
well maybe you should go to therapy it
was like that kind of situation but it's
crazy he thought he was crazy that he
was like talking about that so Randy
gets mad and he's like well you're
obviously not gonna help me
uh you know and he just told him hey you
need to go to a therapist and he's like
okay well I'm out of here so uh Randy
said that he went to like a whole bunch
of different churches and they all
pretty much gave him the run around like
the same kind of story it's like we
don't believe witchcraft is real and you
should probably go see a therapist um
love Jesus bye it was just that kind of
situation
so after all of this Randy decides well
since witchcraft got us into this
problem maybe white witchcraft will get
us out which you know that's that's a
pretty that's a pretty uh you know a
good thing to think I guess now Belva
the mom
she's not a fan of this idea but they've
tried everything else
so they decide okay well we're gonna do
this
so they call this white witch guy whose
name is Mike Mike the witch
I think they said his last name was
basic it sounded like basic
now he's a Wiccan obviously so he comes
to the house now I should note
he they interviewed him on the show like
the real guy which is funny because
considering how this went I don't know
if I'd wanted to be on the show or not
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah but
so he's on there and he's basically well
I've never done this before
but you know I guess he was the only one
around
so he comes to the house and he does
like a ring of protection right so he
has like the salt and all that [ __ ] and
he's like walking around the house three
times or whatever this is like the like
I said it's his first attempt at
exercising demons he's like a [ __ ]
Wiccan trainee or something
so he said that while he was walking
around the house doing the protection
ring that the wind picked up
uh you know that could mean a lot of
things on the show they showed it was
like a win picked up and then it was
like a [ __ ] storm like it was crazy
but it could have just been oh it's a
little Breezy you know what I mean I
don't know
so he said that
because the wind picked up like the more
he walked around that it was like
something trying to stop him that was
like the perception that he had like the
evil trying to stop him so he's like
well I must be doing it right because
they're trying to stop me so when he
finished the ring he said the wind
stopped or the storm stopped or whatever
the [ __ ] it was
so he then does the whole pentagram
thing with the salt and the candles and
all that stuff and then he does starts
doing the ceremony now nothing much
happened during the ceremony like proper
other than like the candles flickering
which I was like well that's kind of
what candles do but okay
um so then like to finish the ceremony
off like Mike goes around like blowing
the candles out and then everyone's like
oh okay cool it's over that was easy and
then uh all hell breaks loose like the
whole [ __ ] I don't know if this
really happened I doubt it but it's like
the whole house starts shaking and like
all kind of crazy [ __ ] happens you know
what I mean was there storm outside
again I kind of think so because you
would watched it like just now
um yeah I don't really remember
something like that but like the house
starts shaking and everybody's like oh
no we baby yeah
um and Tammy who is up in her bedroom
she looks out the window and at first it
looks like a tree it's very Poltergeist
moment uh she looks at it first it looks
like a tree but then she keeps looking
and then brah like it's a demon that's
like a jump scare you know what I mean
and she's like starts screaming and
freaking out so you know what I mean uh
you know screaming her head up so uh I
like that the that the narrator was like
Mike's ring of protection has failed
[Laughter]
you failed yeah and like I said that's
why I was saying I just thought it was
funny that the actual mic was on the
show it's like yep I [ __ ] it up
like apparently like I've made
everything worse I mean that's what they
said that's that's what Randy said it's
like yeah he made it worse so uh so he's
just like well
um I I this is where I came in and he
just leaves you know what I mean yeah
he's like sorry I didn't really know
what I was doing well Poltergeist tends
to just affirm whatever you're whatever
you're doing so if you're if you think
it's a demon it becomes more demonic
um um and you know it'll just get
stronger or more violent that's what
they did
I went in there and treated it like a
demon it became a demon
yeah and I feel like that happens a lot
on these because it's like well even a
lot of times it's not just picking I
mean picking on the wiccans yeah picking
on the wicked but um that's it's not
just picking on them because a lot of
times in these shows like they'll call a
priest like a Catholic priest or
whatever and they'll come in and they'll
make it worse too and they're trying to
get rid of it and they're fighting
something and it can't go away it's a
part it's a part of the person who's
projecting it so it fights for its own
Survival you know what I mean you know
if you tell it it's evil it goes I'm not
yeah [ __ ] out go away no you know again
I know it can't go away it's part of him
you know
so you have to get it to kind of like
rejoin kind of like SP kind of like kind
of like Kirk and his mirror self when
they had to get back in the transporter
and go back in together because they
needed each other the evil one the evil
Kirk and the good Kirk like that yeah
so
using some kind of a religious Faith to
try to kind of
make a bomb you know what I mean and get
a piece going as is a much better way of
doing it you know exercise or something
look how bad exorcisms go and here's the
thing
the exorcism that they based the movie
Exorcist on was the Poltergeist and the
exorcism failed
well they did a bunch of them yeah you
cannot exercise something out of a
person when that's an integral part of
that person's soul you know it's not
going anywhere
yeah eventually they when they stopped
[ __ ] with it eventually it went away
we resolved itself stop [ __ ] with it
yeah stop [ __ ] with it it's somebody
was saying do you think you could get
these like dogs these invisible ghost
dogs could you pick them up on infrared
or anything no they're not really there
if you go back look at some of this
Quantum Soul Theory you know the from
Stuart hammeroff and oh what's his name
Pam Rose
uh what they're talking about is quantum
particles they're talking about the same
thing
that a soul is made out of for the thing
that makes you feel like you are real or
the thing that makes you feel like
you're here your point of view
a person who's doing this making a
poltergeist
can
project these Quantum particles and
they're not even projected out like on
an arm they just appear they just appear
where you need them and they don't
really have any Mass
uh but they can manipulate objects it
can move object it can
um make an arrangement and arrange
things in a pattern make a smiley face
scribble some stuff
they might they seem to be able to make
sound
um
they can make heat they could buy
accelerating molecules
but there's nothing there it's it's just
some kind of quantum particles there's
probably slightly in another dimension
physically
um they have energy but I don't think
they have any Mass
you know does a soul have a mass no
I don't think so they did that
experiment yeah
like where they they put dead people on
a big scale to see if they got lighter
ones they're lighter and they didn't
even have their scales weren't very
sensitive but uh no there's no Mass to
any of these and there's
but evidently there's Force to it
and
Poltergeist that we saw evidently based
on
the situation not only could they move
an object they can make an object
teleport
because some of that stuff was appearing
in those rooms we'd be have the door
closed
when you'd open the door and look in
there and be new objects in there and it
would be seconds you know
some of those objects came from
downstairs and they didn't pass us
so they either passed through solid
objects to arrive there or they
teleported I think some of it happened
so fast that they teleported they didn't
always teleport because they could throw
an object too
but I think they could teleport an
object
which that's some spooky [ __ ] when you
think about it
but it's not normal physics
but evidently we don't know anything
about physics that's that's really what
it gets down to we don't really know
that much about physics we think we know
we can predict some stuff there's
something else we don't know
Zach says I don't know why but him
talking about feeling the dog tooth on
his leg maybe think of how much I love
the sound of a dog sniffing from under a
door
that's some kinky [ __ ] man
well I like kind of waking up in the
middle of the night and hearing Pokey
crunching her treats like
like I can hear that from across the
room because I'm like oh it's Pookie
getting a treat that's so funny I
guarantee you there was no dog there
and you could probably do all kinds of
you know infrared cameras and everything
it wouldn't record anything
it seemed to not like to do anything
under observation everything was
some stuff happened while you were
looking at it but it mostly liked to do
things when it was just slightly out of
your view
as if as if it couldn't do some of this
stuff when you were looking at it it
kind of had to be in a
in the shadow zone of the of the maybe
like maybe an object's there maybe it's
not
kind of like has something to do with
the
perspective and um
point of view looking at something made
it more real Maybe
it's it's something weird like that
if nobody's looking at it it's in a
realm where where it exists and it can
or it's in a it's in a state of being
where the Poltergeist is if that's what
I call it and it can manipulate that
object easy more easily because it is
equally unobserved that'd be maybe a
good way to put it they're both being
unobserved
and when you open the door it's it's the
object's already moved but you knew you
know it wasn't there before that type of
deal you know
but you never really sometimes you we
did catch some things moving or at the
end of their motion
or at the very beginning it's just hard
to say because some yeah
it just seemed to be very reluctant
or unable to really kind of or at least
reluctant let's say that it was like it
was reluctant to let allow you to
see it do everything it could do it
wanted you to see the aftermath but not
the process
it was a mystifying man I was a kid
seeing it and Lois and red were there
and we were just a [ __ ] astounded it
seemed unreal you know
it was real though weird
Ben actually makes a good point says you
never hear about the exorcisms that work
out just fine only the negative
experiences are newsworthy yeah I guess
so
Danny says Roland doe that's the if if
you didn't know that's the uh the kid
that was extra that The Exorcist was
based on yeah that's not his real name
but that was the name he went by uh was
successful so much so that the wing at
the hospital they were in was forever
haunted and closed to the public and
supposedly the bed the exorcism took
place in is that uh is that a hangar at
Wright-Patterson Air Force yeah it was a
good restroom hold on I wonder is it
really it's over there Area 51 no it's
not
laughs
that's I mean it's a fascinating story
though like um I read about it a little
bit in my book but
it's just that's a crazy [ __ ] story
I never know I don't know if they ever
said what that real kid's name was I've
heard Roland doe and I've also heard
um
what was it Ronald Mannheim or something
like something Mannheim but they said uh
but neither one of those was his real
name I don't think because he was like a
minor and it was like a big [ __ ]
media story you know what I mean
so uh let's see where was I okay
so yeah we were laughing about
we were laughing about the wicked like
coming in there and being like aren't
you glad I came over to help you like
[ __ ] everything up and he's just like
well my work here is done he just kind
of just wet
he's like bye so I don't I don't know
like if um I don't know if Randy and
them like actually paid the wicked too
to to to cleanse the house but it's like
yeah they needed a refund on that [ __ ]
so yeah but he just left you know
feeling bad I guess so at this point
um I guess Randy's like really bummed
out because he's like well now what the
hell I'm gonna am I gonna do because
it's like I've done everything I can
think of
and nothing is working so he goes into
like this really bad depression and it's
like he thinks he's going insane blah
blah
so he finally I guess he was in the same
I thought it looked like the same
bookstore as the place where he got the
witchcraft book from before but I could
be wrong about that but he's like so he
was in there and I guess it was a friend
of his that worked there or went there
or something like that his name was
Paula and he started talking to her
about it and just like confessed the
whole story it's like oh my God this
weekend came over and like made it even
worse and all of a sudden it's like you
know he tells us the whole story
so Paula said hey I know this woman
who's like a Healer uh so why don't you
call her up and he's like okay might as
well like there's nothing else to do
right I think her name was Nora or
something but she wasn't like um she was
on the show but they put her like in
silhouette like I guess she didn't want
her face on the on the show
so she said that she came over the house
and Randy looked like really sickly uh
when she met him and he said that he was
just so depressed he just like wanted to
die all this other kind of stuff so Nora
like I said is just kind of like well
she's a big healer so it's like well you
have to like totally believe in God or
you know or otherwise it might be able
to help you and so they just do like
this Deliverance Prayer so it's not even
like an exorcism it was more like just
kind of like they were praying and [ __ ]
um but uh first I guess she was saying
the prayer and like told him to say it
and then like but he couldn't say it so
I guess they were trying to imply that
like the demon or whatever it was like
it was like you know what I mean like he
can't say it or whatever
um he said he started feeling himself
going partially unconscious that's what
he said
um and then on the show I'm sure this
didn't happen in real life but um his
eyes went all black like you know he got
the black contact lenses or whatever and
his chair flies backward which was
actually pretty impressive again I'm
pretty sure it didn't happen like that
in real life
but it just went like and it hit the
wall
and then uh from there it kind of goes
into your standard like possession
exorcism deal uh you know not exactly
the same because she was a lot more
low-key but apparently though Nora was
successful in exercising him and Randy
accepts Jesus and bloody blah
uh Nora blesses the original house too
because remember they moved this is a
different house but they would go back
to the original house and with the bones
in it and she blesses that one too just
like to be on the safe side I guess uh
and she says she wanted to close the
bottomless pit that had been opened
Randy
yeah you know what I mean yeah uh so
Randy basically said at the end don't
dabble in witchcraft kids I mean that's
not what he said but that's what I wrote
down it's just because that's what it
sounded like
hey it's Pookie yeah don't dabble in
witchcraft Pookie she's like oh she's
like I don't really want to be on a show
why not yeah everybody wants to see you
pokey see you look at your little face
everybody wants to see you yeah okay
she's like um yeah okay bye-bye
yeah
she's like why you always gotta pick me
up yeah but yeah so that was the end of
that show and as I mentioned uh I found
this guy uh like I said Randy Urban is
his name e-r-v-i-n
and he wrote a book called the house on
Church Street
so you could probably find the house if
you really wanted to like I said it's in
Standish Michigan somewhere the house
doesn't have anything to do with the
incident but no but I'm just saying that
if you you know if you wanted to because
I know some people do but uh yeah I
didn't read the book but it's very short
and a lot of people it got terrible
reviews I think it only had like one and
a half stars or something like it only
had like a handful of reviews and like I
said I think the main criticisms were
too short like they felt like ripped off
or it was stealth evangelism like I said
or
um it was like really badly written like
I think even one of the I'm trying to
remember like how they worded it because
I laughed out loud like when they said
it it was something like it wasn't like
um this guy's either an illiterate or he
plays one on TV but it was something
like that you know what I mean that's
just what you know what I mean and I
just thought it was very funny like the
way they had worded it and I was like
well that's kind of a nice way to put it
like a very backhanded compliment but
yeah so again this seemed like a similar
narrative to Spellbound and as such I
have the same
um kind of like caveats about it because
I do kind of feel like this
this kind of stuff especially if they
come out at the end and be like oh well
you know I played around with witchcraft
or I played around with Satanism and
then you know everything was [ __ ] up
until I accepted Jesus into my life it's
just that's a very very common
Evangelical narrative that they like to
like pass around and so I'm never
entirely sure how much of this is
[ __ ]
my opinion of it is this
how the phenomenon is described fits in
with what I've seen
um
discount now the religious narratives
that go along with it that might be a
common reaction
people might actually that's true come
up with that but the phenomenon itself
as as described
I say plausible
plausible
similar to similar to what I saw
the things that were different
he's a little older than average of the
uh of most of your Poltergeist yeah he
was early 20s early 20s usually it
happens in the teens
uh but it can happen later
usually the first time happens a lot
earlier though
but he might be just a different case
trying to think what else is different
a lot of it though like you said it was
kind of similar because it did start out
with
um weird noises which is a very common
way for Poltergeist activity to start
out like weird Phantom noises like
footsteps and it's not really how it
started started with tension in the
house he finds bones yeah
then they don't turn the bones in
and then he goes to an occult bookstore
and tries to summon a spirit to help him
find treasure okay and that sets up the
situation that sets up a situation for
Poltergeist
and maybe that's why he's older
you know what I mean yeah
because it's a slightly different way
usually a kid doesn't do that a kid
doesn't move into a house by themselves
true doesn't find bones by themselves
doesn't try to go go to a cult bookstore
and summon a a demon or a spirit to help
him find treasure
it's an older guy that goes through this
but it might be sufficient he's
sufficiently young enough and has enough
of a [ __ ] psychic charge where he can
get the ball rolling and then once the
balls roll and remember how he said he
felt sick and everything yeah and
drained
Poltergeist
he just started it later than normal
which is not happening that's not
unprecedented I mean like I said I wrote
about some cases before where it was
like it's almost always teenagers but
not always not always and he uh
he interprets it from a religious point
of view because his family and his
upbringing and being a cultural
Christian and everything
he wasn't a Christian at the time
and then maybe uh or so he said
we see red reacted to it a little bit
like that
he he reacted to it and so so to kind of
Lois they reacted to it from a kind of a
religious stand because that was that
was the only way they could interpret
what they were seeing
you know so
yeah for that generation that's that's
how that's what they do yeah that's the
framework they would expect from they go
through yeah and that actually this you
know like I said whether this really
happened or not I mean this was
before yours yeah I mean this happened
and he's even older right yeah 1974
right yeah so yeah
yeah I think it's plausible if it
happened I'm just saying
yeah the phenomenon it's hard to say
it's hard to say it's hard to say yeah
if it's a fake it's a good fake
well like I said some of the I liked
that some of the details of it were
specific like I liked the specific
details of like the creepy organ yeah
yeah and like the dog yeah like the
sound of the dog and like the feel of
the dog's teeth and stuff like that
that's a very specific
detail not just oh you know a cup fell
over or just like random kind of or
knocking or on the walls or whatever the
sound of an organ playing from a corner
of a room then you can't find anything
there
that's kind of compelling I'm like yeah
that sounds like something it would do
it's like something the mind would do
mine didn't do that but that was a good
idea had that been suggested mine would
do that
well the thing about it was that yours
made that weird watery voice noise that
came out of the car so it was like same
kind of thing where it was like a weird
noise that was coming out of the corner
when there was yeah it went on for
several seconds I just ran from it I was
like no no to the [ __ ] out I don't
believe I didn't want that thing talking
to me
yeah
but yeah there were some things about
that that
so like you said if it's a fake they
maybe did their research about it yeah
which is kind of strange because they
said he couldn't write worth [ __ ] in the
book so what are the chances of a dude
like that cooking up a good fake well
that's the thing though is that
sometimes I don't know and I've had this
experience too generally and I know this
is probably unfair but you know because
um you know I'm kind of like a stickler
for grammar and spelling and stuff like
that so if I read somebody's written
stuff like even if it's a text or
something like that and it's all like
misspelled or grammatically incorrect
I'm gonna like see I'm not gonna assume
like they're stupid but I'll just be
like hmm you know what I mean
um but on the other hand I have known
many people that were actually like
really really intelligent uh you know
and when you spoke to them they seemed
really intelligent or very articulate
but then when they wrote for whatever
reason yeah
um it just wasn't working out for them
let's put it like that
um and I know that some people have you
know uh what's what's it called were
they dyslexia
um so some of it might be that whereas
they're much better like verbally than
they're than they are written I guess
whereas I'm like the opposite
I'm thinking that uh [ __ ] what was I
gonna say
I mean I had something good I was going
to say about this
it's um it's it's an interesting case
if it's a fake it's a good fake
and I don't think a guy like this is
going to be oh here's another thing that
was that was good about it
there are several witnesses to this case
some of the other ones we've talked
about there isn't really any Witnesses
just that one one person's story right
this one you've got a couple Witnesses
yeah like his mom and his sister yeah
and they were both on the show right
wait was his mom his mom was on there
right his sister his well his sister was
for sure yeah so that's that's saying
something too so he's not cooking it up
on his own
so
I think I think there's I think it's
plausible I think I think yeah you just
you just think that he's attributing it
to the wrong thing maybe yeah he doesn't
know about rspk he doesn't really know
what Poltergeist is
which that kind of adds that kind of
goes into his favor because if you know
about Poltergeist sometimes it might
prevent it from happening
you know what I mean because the fear
isn't there yeah you need to have fear
and certain negative emotions to to
generate this phenomenon it helps well
you're you're um Tom pathesis is that
this hypothesis yeah is that
youth you knowing that it's you uh
suppresses it yeah
yeah it might
I guess knowing it knowing that it's you
suppresses it uh I can't imagine I mean
I can imagine somebody being able to do
this at will there was supposed to be
that Soviet girl she could do it move a
compass and move needles and stuff
when I'm thinking of somebody who's
doing it at will I'm thinking of [ __ ]
Darth Vader remember the scene where
Darth Vader and Luke are down there in
the same the lightsaber fight and then
all of a sudden all the stuff jumps off
the wall and starts hitting [ __ ] Luke
going out the window yeah Vader knows
that's him doing it he just grabs on
some he grabs onto some [ __ ] make sure
he doesn't get sucked
take that you [ __ ] you yeah
it'd be from from what I've seen it'd be
really hard to do that at will
I don't know if it's possible
although you've seen me work myself up
and [ __ ] do [ __ ] in front of people
with the remote and stuff yeah but you
weren't aware of it right that's well
that's the point that I was gonna make
is that you weren't trying to do it I
wasn't trying to do it was happening all
you were thinking about was that you
were mad and you were frustrated yeah
um you know and then something just
happened like you weren't concentrating
on and the thing that moved wasn't
anything that you were looking at yeah
and you guys saw it move and I was just
in it I was just zoned out yeah and then
once I felt it coming over me I stood up
goes oh yeah yeah I feel it I feel it
and I looked down there was a stack of
coins at my feet yeah and and uh
and Dimitri was like do it again Tom do
it again yeah he's like no no no no no
you're offended me that's funny yeah do
it again do it again
because I'm afraid to get out of get out
of [ __ ] hand
you know yeah I just kind of feel like
every time it happens
more recently yeah it happened when you
were either not thinking about it like
you were zoned out or you were really
really mad about something yeah
not so much mad frustrated right yeah
more it's not so much anger it's
frustration right
weird although it happened when I was
asleep too yeah opening the ring the
doorbells and opened maybe you were
dreaming something [ __ ] yeah well that
was during that time it kept turning the
television on
yeah we were writing the book and it was
turning the television on at weird times
got it turned that [ __ ] TV on all the
time and it would turn it on in the
bedroom
one time it turned it on but usually it
turned on the living room living room TV
pretty much every other day yeah every
other day or every third day they would
do it for like every other day or every
third day it would do it for like about
a week at a time then it would stop it
it would stop for a couple weeks and
then we'd do it again I just got so used
to it that it didn't bother him anymore
like I'd get up in the morning like go
in the kitchen and make coffee or like
get my lunch for work or something like
that and be like well TV's on again he
had a TV would be on and it'd be on a
screensaver yeah and I couldn't get it
to go to that screensaver by turning the
TV on remember that yeah it was hard to
get that screensaver but that's what it
would be on
and it turned on in the middle of the
night in our room
one time just TV came on yeah that was
pretty creepy yeah even though we knew
what it was but I was still kind of like
creeped out yeah you said it was looking
at you one time in the bathroom
when you're walking through to it wasn't
like the bathroom but it was in front of
the sink remember
you said you felt it looking at you
um you couldn't see it though it wasn't
I don't it wasn't so much looking at me
and I feel it looking at me I felt
something
behind me yeah or like it
brushed against my leg or like it I just
felt like something was behind me yeah
where was I at the time I don't think
you were home I think you were out she
was out somewhere
so I just I don't use my dad's house one
yeah that's when you were in Mississippi
that's when you were in Mississippi yeah
that's right yeah that's right that's
right because I was like I knew that you
weren't home and like you hadn't been
home it was either when you were in
Mississippi visiting your dad or when
you were in the hospital after Beijing
bit you okay so because it was sometime
when you weren't home for like several
days it might have been when I got I had
a stretch yeah because you were in the
hospital for like yeah five or six five
days something like that right so you
can generate this and I don't think it's
that rare
I think um I think probably I'm thinking
that probably depending on your age your
status your health
um
what kind of a personality or what level
of intelligence you have
I probably think that maybe 30 percent
of the people can do this
um but it's more likely to happen than
somebody going through puberty
and it has to have right social
conditions
stressful Family Life poverty helps
um I kind of feel like if you're in an
environment where you have to like
suppress your emotions yeah suppressed
emotions like you're not really allowed
to express yourself in a healthy manner
right and there has to be kind of like a
certain level of discipline in the house
where uh bottled up emotions you know
that that'll do it so the emotions have
to go somewhere it's not intelligence
doing this intelligence is just one of
the factors this is emotion doing it
okay whatever whatever does this is
emotionally emotionally driven
it's a weird phenomenon very weird
Ben says Poltergeist sometimes manifest
around people who are suffering senility
or end of life confusion it adds to the
psychic ability hypothesis people no
longer able to control or support their
abilities may cause phenomena I have to
like look into the materials going I
wonder if there's enough cases to do a
show about that that's a good idea I
mean because like I said whenever you
talk about Poltergeist almost everybody
talks about teenagers because I kind of
feel like 95 percent of the time of the
time it is teenagers but I have written
about a couple cases where it was like
you know older or not even older but
like middle aged women I've seen that
happen
um I did write about one case that was
it that happened in Atlanta that was two
old people like an old couple but I
don't know like specifically I don't
know enough about that like to know what
would have caused that and it manifested
in a really weird way like blood puddles
you remember that one yeah remember that
one but I wonder if there'd be like
enough cases to kind of look into that
where it was just like old people like
having weird [ __ ] happen around a
[ __ ] a rip on Stephen King for being
a douche
he gets a lot of [ __ ] right because he
did his research early on with a lot of
the parapsychology that was going on in
the 60s and the 70s
and some of this [ __ ] that we're talking
about actually kind of appears in the
[ __ ] Extended Cut of Dr sleep movie
and The Shining a lot of that's in there
uh kind of like psychic abilities rspk
type stuff
um Danny grows up and he can uh
basically talk people to death or help
them pass on to the other side as their
[ __ ] Souls start to detach from their
body and he uh what could he what was he
doing he could he could kind of re he
was reliving stuff with him wasn't he
as they were dying sort of I think he
was just kind of like easing their
transition yeah like that was like his
ability he could see
the past and certain things that
happened he saw him in the form of
ghosts which that's what I think a ghost
is if you see a ghost I think it's just
a an echo of the past like reading a
recording
and it may not it's probably non-local I
don't really you might be able to see a
ghost in a certain location
but you might be able to see that same
ghost in another location you probably
just you could probably just access it
remotely if you wanted to
now if you had that ability
um accessing ghosts remotely yeah you're
like you might not see a ghost that's
somewhere far away because you're kind
of just seeing in the past and if you're
going to see the past it doesn't matter
where your location is if you can see
across time then that means you can see
across space you wouldn't have to be
there in that location
think about it true you know that's true
and Poltergeist was non-local
it didn't seem when I had that out of
body experience I could be in two places
at once looking at the same wall locker
from the front and the back
simultaneously and I was like whoa that
was [ __ ] weird and then it
yeah I'll tell about it I talked about
it talked about that on a show
when I
was in the Army and had an out of Body
Experience
in front of my roommate he saw it happen
it freaked him out
he wouldn't talk to me after that yeah
he said what was that I said I came out
of my body it was dude no man
but there's the vibrations in the room
things [ __ ] rattling microwave
snapping and popping
rocking the refrigerator
and I was looking down from the sea then
I could see everything I could see
through things
it just look like energy
colored colored shapes
weird I saw him running towards me just
looked like a black cloud cover and
everything I couldn't see him as a
person it just looked like a black cloud
that's how things looked
pretty weird yeah it was hard to stand
still wherever you looked you went over
there
you know just staying still and seeing
things
and you can see 360 Degrees all in
directions at once so you can see you
can change your point of view instantly
so there wasn't even like non-local you
weren't really in a location you were
wherever you you were in all locations
you're in all locations yeah
so that Poltergeist can do that
yeah yeah
all right are we have we wrapped it up
yeah okay yeah so I guess we will be
back tomorrow talking about another
Quentin Tarantino movie the hateful
eight yeah it's a good movie we're gonna
see it again that's yeah we're gonna
watch it uh this evening yeah and then
we'll talk about that tomorrow
so that should be fun and then maybe I
don't know I might try to do like some
more Christmas [ __ ] I put up a Christmas
double feature thing over on my scare
Salon like if you haven't uh subscribed
to my scare Salon or my crime and
Memorial channels please go do that
because I'm trying to like I said I'm
trying to get a thousand people so I can
monetize the [ __ ] but you know yeah
we're getting there but it's slow yeah
that's right plug some stuff Jen now we
need to plug in get the show going we
need more patrons uh [ __ ] man the patron
money [ __ ] vanished over the past
couple years went from like nearly like
700 a month down to like 300 a month and
we can feel that that's enough to make a
big difference
so we're looking for more patrons if you
guys love the show man please become a
patron even if it's only like a couple
bucks a month because there's a lot of
you know there's a lot there's a lot of
y'all now you know we have almost 13
000. 13 000 people we're almost at
thirteen thousand if everybody gave a
dollar that would be a huge difference
that's yeah that's true even though we
only get half of that that'd be like six
thousand that'd be like six thousand six
grand a month totally implied
implausible no you don't ever get a
return like that you know I mean a lot
of those followers or a lot of
subscribers are probably long gone are
dead you know well the thing about it
too is that I mean I think about it
sometimes too it's like I have like a
million subscription like I subscribe to
like tons and tons of channels you know
I don't have well yeah I don't have time
to watch them all
so and it's like and I really only give
because I actually give a little bit of
money on patreon to a to a couple of
other uh you know YouTubers that I like
but you know I can't obviously afford to
like give a dollar to every single one I
right subscribe to because then all my
money would be gone because I have like
a lot of but I mean there's a lot that I
wish I could so I kind of feel like even
though yeah it seems like oh we have
almost 13 000 subscribers but it's never
plug and we never show commercials and
she's already got beautiful commercials
made she always forgets to show the
commercials well I don't want to sell
anything well we this is a businessman
you got the cute red hair and you got
big glasses and everything
[Laughter]
better than b is better than starting
the only fan and just putting titties in
the camera although that's probably
where the damn money's at just put your
boobs in the camera foreign
hey I could do like that that lady on
the on the Netflix show last night that
was wrestling dudes for yeah for 300 an
hour 300 an hour wrestling and she said
I don't know if I actually believe her
but she said that she didn't have sex
with any of them they just wanted they
just wanted to wrestle them she probably
she probably had sex with some of them
that's what I'm saying yeah or things
like sex
that's it's a it's a decent documentary
like I said we watch it's a it's like a
three-part documentary on Netflix it's
called Killer's alley yeah and it's
about uh Sally McNeil who shot her
husband she was a bodybuilder and her
husband was a bodybuilder yeah and she
shot him back in the uh 90s
and uh like I said I was just flipping
through Netflix and I said oh look it's
true crime which I like and you know
bodybuilding which you like so yeah
let's let's watch that
[Laughter]
Tammy said Tom's titties
yeah actually I'd get to the point where
I'd be the [ __ ] Breadwinner around
her like step aside let me get this
camera
that's what I mean it's like maybe you
should start maybe you should start
wearing only fans wearing some like
low-cut shirts
solo scenes and [ __ ] there you go yeah
you could do that yeah
all right so uh yeah so tomorrow uh be
sure to come by same time same channel
we're going to be talking about the
hateful eight so thank you everybody for
dropping by this evening have a good
rest of your evening and we'll see you
guys again tomorrow bye